hey I'm Vanessa Hudgens and I'm Adam
pally you know your name you know hi I'm
Eva Longoria I'm Nina Dobrev and we are
doing the wired complete the wire Google
wire googling a wired wired autocomplete
interview kind of like what I did there
like blank Nina Dobrev blank Oh what
does Nina Dobrev eat I mean I go through
waves what are your favorite image
truffle cheeseburger and fries kind of
girl and then I feel guilty for eating
said truffle cheese burger with fries
and then I eat shakes for breakfast for
like a week
oh I was like milkshakes that's not good
either no what kind of dog does Nina ha
I am a rescue puppy
her name is math when I don't know why
I'm talking with a weird voice from the
top dogs I mean I think I in my brain I
think maverick talks like this what is
Nina do my favorite color it changes
it's what your favorite color can change
Nina when I was little it was red but
then I painted my bedroom Brad like all
the walls and the ceiling and the bed
sheets were red as well and it was just
like I felt like I was in a target yeah
so now it's like a lilac purple lavender
lavender there you what doesn't mean
that don't live do to stay in shape
eats truffle burger box and I run and I
just sort of do all kinds of different
things I like to shake it up okay what
is Vanessa Hudgins zodiac sign
I'm Sagittarius I'm easygoing fun loving
and loyal calm out that's a face shape
what is my face shape oh this is a
minefield for me I'm gonna say perfect
wow that's a good answer
thank you that's what does Vanessa
Hudgens Drive i drive an Audi a7 call
now I feel like I have to do a new new
voice and I feel like there's some
magical number that people can call to
get an Audi or information about your
zodiac sign what is Vanessa Hudgins
style chic that's what I like to think
at least that's a really good
description we'll say does Eva Longoria
know Spanish nada que yo hablo espanol
does Eva Longoria have a tattoo I had
six tattoos and I removed them all that
hurt yes it hurts more than getting them
but fun fact because I had a wedding
date to my ex-husband on my wrist and
when I was campaigning for Obama Obama
looked at my wrist he goes now is that
really a good idea and I was like no in
retrospect probably not
where does Eva Longoria live this is a
very good question and also one that you
probably shouldn't answer no I live that
between LA and Mexico City but I'm
really a gypsy I live wherever my
husband is that's home does Nina Dobrev
have any siblings I do I have a brother
who's older than me by five years and
everybody thinks that he's younger than
me which is offensive yeah because then
it's like am I not spending enough money
on my face cream yeah what should I be
doing don't sing in the shower in front
of my dog if I need to fend off
murderers
I could sing and then they would run
away doesn't even Dobrev have eyelash
extension I'm not saying I don't say I
know because if you google it I don't
even think the real answer wouldn't come
off well are they asking if my eyelashes
are real I guess well I think I can't
answer this one I really did buy them
what does Adam pally tattoo say oh I
have a lot of them I have one of my
chest I got when I was very young that
is my Hebrew name at the time it was
like kind of cool and badass but now it
looks like I've spent time in a tel-aviv
prison and I'm someone's property what
is Adam pally in it's very nice I guess
to be googled like that but also very
hurtful what Adam name means my name
means the earth what rhymes Adam I feel
like you get away with it but I would
say what rhymes Adam Adam okay
Vanessa Hudgins Spanish see yes - my way
no no I'm not
partly my
mom's dad was from Castillo Spain so
Spanish vegan I am pescetarian fish yeah
I mean wheat milk dating 2018 yeah I'm
dating the year 2018 yeah it's been a
really solid relationship I've been with
my boyfriend for like almost seven years
so it's tough my wife recently left me
for 1979 where's Vanessa Hudgins parents
from my mom is from the Philippines and
my dad was born in the States
I don't think anyone would ask me that
question because it's rather obvious
that my mom was a falafel and my dad was
what is Eva Longoria hair color doesn't
your hair color change a lot a lot what
is Eva Longoria filming in Wales I was
shooting a BBC series but that was like
for two seconds
why did Eva Longoria duh get her
master's what did you what did you get
your master's in Chicano Studies which
is mexican-american history in the
United States that's cool it's so cool
that people Google that what blank did
Eva Longoria ah what to one college
college yet yes I went to Texas A&M in
Kingsville and then I went to CSUN Cal
State Northridge who is Holly's life
that's very nice my wife is my high
school sweetheart because I'm such a
dang cute little nugget and I love
romance who does Adam pally
I run the gamut I mean on a good day it
could run all the way up to like you
look like Chris O'Donnell on a bad day
it can go all the way down to like is
that Josh GAD its ass large swath how
tall is that impelling I'm a Jewish 511
mm-hmm so once again it's like anywhere
between 510 and six foot for real but I
slouch and I have bad posture
I've even measured at like six foot but
I really cut more of like a 5/10 figure
Oh
Joey people probably thought they saw
you at Coachella I feel like you're the
number one celebrity people are like you
know I'm sure that conversation has had
it like 90% of specializes in Palm
Springs I'm telling you dude I saw
Vanessa Hudgens buying beer no you
didn't I played a
rizelle I'm so proud of it here let's do
these together okay will do is Eva
Longoria and Evan Longoria related no
but fun fact nothing Longoria is a very
famous baseball player and when he was a
rookie that's like when Desperate
Housewives was at its peak and so he
would go to bat and they would be like
Eva Eva and he hated it oh no and he got
Rookie of the Year his rookie year and I
send him champagne I said
congratulations I'm so sorry we share
the same name okay and then he sent me
back a jersey signed and he said it's an
honor to share your name he was very
kind is Nina Dobrev a vegetarian
absolutely not no she is not I love all
the beets Briana young and restless Oh
Anya thinking about a my young and the
restless' I was on young adresses that
was one of my first acting gig oh cool
is Nina Dobrev burglar Bulgarian oh I
thought they'd do it you a burglar no I
mean I've stolen a couple hearts in my
day
I am Bulgarian yes do you speak
Bulgarian I do it was my first language
well let's hear some Bulgarian no Louise
come to visit does he feel dog-days no
but she will cut us up there i neva
langoria tea and I'll do it off silly
film
da perfect and by the way you said job
which is yes in Bulgarian right after I
said make sure to check out Eva Longoria
in this movie because she's amazing and
you're like ah Gloria in a relationship
I'm married so yes is even very vegan we
both thought that I was vegan for a
minute and I
we're like a mom oh yeah and I was like
no can't do it I'm from Texas hard pass
thanks for watching so wired
autocomplete interview